Hallo, guten Abend.
Ilgas ist mein Name. Heute bin ich die zuständige Arschten auf dieser Station.
Und würde gerne mit Ihnen das Analyse gespräch führen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Verzerrung, ich habe Ihren Namen nicht ganz verstanden.
Wie ist Ihr Name, bitte?
Ilgas.
Il, wie? Il?
Ilgas, ja. Ilgas.
Ilgas.
Verzerrung, was ist das für ein Name, bitte?
Hawa Ilgas.
Okay, woher kommt diese Name?
Mein Name ist eine Arabische Name.
Ah, sie kommen aus Arabien.
Aus der Türkei.
Ach, aus der Türkei. Ach so.
Welchen aber? Gut Deutsch.
Ja, ich habe ihn gegründert.
Aber sie tragen keinen Kopf durch. Geht das?
Sie können ohne Kopf durchlaufen.
Ja.
Das sind aber eine moderne Türkei.
Das ist aber schön.
Sehr gut.
Ich spreche aber gut Deutsch. Ja, bitte.
Danke.
Ja, bis zum Kondokten.
Alles klar.
Bevor wir über Ihre aktuelle Besprechung sprechen,
brauche ich ein paar Informationen über Ihre persönliche Date.
Wie heißen Sie das?
Mein Name ist Manuel Heckmann.
Manuel? Können Sie bitte Ihren Nachnamen buchstabieren?
Heckmann, ja, natürlich.
Das ist Heinrich Emil Caesar Karl,
M. W. Marta, A. W. Anton,
und dann Nordpol Nordpol. Heckmann.
Okay, double.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 54 Jahre alt.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 1.15.1970.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich glaube, ich bin ein bisschen kleiner geworden.
Ich war mal 1,78.
Wie schwer sind Sie?
Ich sage, das ist so wichtig, Frau Doktor.
Ich bin ein bisschen etwas schwer.
Ich glaube, so bei 110 kg.
110 kg, ja.
Alle Informationen sind wichtig,
über Ihre allgemeine Gesundheit zu wissen.
Danke schön für die Informationen.
Was für Sie zu uns, Herr Heckmann?
Was kann ich für Sie tun?
Also, das geht schon länger,
aber es ist seit einigen Tagen,
ich sage, man ist schlimmer geworden,
als ich es zu Ihnen.
Mein linkes Bein ist etwas taub geworden,
und ich habe kein Gefühl mehr im Fuß, an den Zehen.
Danke schön.
Sag mal, haben Sie diese Wischwürde?
Also, wie gesagt, das geht schon länger.
Ich habe seit ein, zwei Jahren schon
ein bisschen Kribbeln gehabt,
aber jetzt seit zwei Wochen ungefähr ist es so schlimm.
Hat es zugenommen.
Okay, und haben Sie Schmerzen in diesem Berat?
Jetzt seit heute Abend habe ich gemerkt,
dass ich Schmerzen habe,
aber vorher ist mir das nicht aufgefallen.
Okay, wie können Sie diese Schmerzen beschreiben?
Sie haben die Schmerzen oder die Schmerzen drücken?
Das war jetzt nur ganz kurz,
und dann habe ich immer meine Füße angeschaut.
Ich habe gesehen, dass an dem kleinen Zehen,
da ist ein kleines Loch,
und so richtige Schmerzen habe ich nicht.
Nur wenn ich meine Schuhe anziehe,
dann merke ich ein bisschen ab.
Ansonsten nicht so oft.
Okay.
Genau sind Sie diese beschwerbenden Taupas in Gas?
Nein, also das ist der Fuß,
der linke Fuß, an dem kleinen Zehen,
an der Seite.
Haben Sie Schwellengunkel, Rötchen oder andere Spemer?
Ich kann es sehr schlecht sehen.
Ich habe einen Spiegel geholt.
Von oben habe ich es nicht gesehen.
Ich habe mich auch schlecht bücken.
Ich habe auch einen dicken Bauch,
und ich kann meinen Fuß kaum sehen.
Wenn ich von oben schaue, sehe ich nichts.
Aber ich habe meinen Fuß gegen einen Spiegel gehalten.
Da habe ich gesehen,
dass unten, an dem kleinen Zehen,
am Rand so ein kleines Loch ist.
Sie meinen, es ist eine offene Wunde.
Ja, es ist eine offene Stelle.
Haben Sie Blüten bemerkt?
Nein, ich habe nichts gemerkt.
Ich muss dazu sagen,
ich schaue meine Füße nicht so oft an.
Ich habe meistens auch Socken an.
Da ist es nicht aufgefallen.
Ich habe es vor zwei Tagen gesagt.
Da waren die Socken etwas blutig und etwas nass.
Einmal hatte ich Schmerzen,
aber dann eigentlich nicht mehr.
Hatten Sie Unfall oder Verlustung und Investition?
Nein.
Passt es Ihnen ein bisschen gut?
Ja, bisher habe ich keine Probleme gehabt.
Okay.
Haben Sie Blässehaut bemerkt?
Blässehaut?
Ist mir nicht aufgefallen.
Können Sie Ihre Fuß gut bewegen?
Ja, ich kann schon laufen.
Manchmal tut das weh, aber ich kann eigentlich schon laufen.
Haben Sie Erwarmen in dieser Stelle bemerkt?
Nein, ich merke überhaupt gar nicht, dass es warm oder kalt ist.
Ich spüre eigentlich wenig oder gar nichts.
Leiden Sie unter Rücken schmerzen?
Ja, das habe ich schon seit lange.
Chronische Rückenschmerzen, das stimmt.
Aber im Moment geht das, da habe ich jetzt weniger Probleme.
Okay.
Okay, Herr Huckmann.
Haben Sie andere Bescheiden?
Nein.
Nein, das ist nur der Fuß.
Ich wollte zeigen, ob man da etwas machen muss.
Hatten Sie früher eine Bescheide?
Nein, das ist das erste Mal.
Herr Huckmann, jetzt kommen Sie zu Ihren Vorerkrankungen.
Haben Sie eine dauerhafte Krankheit?
Ja, ich habe einiges.
Ich habe schon viele Erkrankungen, das stimmt.
Was haben Sie hier?
Ich zeige einmal hier meine Medikamentenliste.
Da habe ich über den Tag 15 Tabletten.
Ich habe hohen Blutdruck.
Ich habe einen Diabetes.
Ich habe schon über 20 Jahre einen Diabetes.
Mein Urulog sagt, meine Prostata macht auch schon Probleme.
Wie viel größer ist es?
Ja, genau.
Ich habe am Herzen schon zwei Stands.
Ich hatte vor zwei Jahren einen Herzkatheter.
Der Doktor hat gesagt, das war gefährlich, kurz vor einem Herzinfarkt.
Aber da konnte man auch einen Herz, zwei Stands einsetzen.
Ich habe schon einige Operationen hinter mir.
Aber Sie hatten keine Herzinfarkt, oder?
Nein, der Doktor hat gemeint, das war kurz davor.
Seit wann haben Sie Blutdruck?
Da war ich ungefähr 40 Jahre alt, als man das erste Mal einen Blutdruck gestellt hat.
Mit 40.
Sie haben schon gesagt, Sie haben auch chronische Rückwärtsschmerzen.
Missen Sie seit wann Sie haben?
Ja, das habe ich schon seit meiner Jugend.
Ich habe da mehrere Bandscheibenvorfälle im Lendenwirbelbereich.
Ich habe dann gestürzt gewesen und hatte ein Wirbelkörperer gebrochen.
Das war eher im Bereich der Brustwirbelsäule.
Ich habe dann auch noch seit fünf Jahren,
dass ein künstliches Hüftgelenk auf der rechten Seite war.
Sie haben Bandscheibenvorfall im Lendenwirbelsäule.
Sie haben Brustwirbel gebrochen.
Ihre Hüftgelenk ist auch gebrochen.
Nein, das war eine Arthrose.
Das ist ein Hüftep.
Ich habe einen Schrittmacher hier oben.
Und wann war diese Operation?
Vor fünf Jahren.
Ich gebe hier mal meine Liste.
Da könnt ihr es angucken.
Das ist für das Herz, für den Diabetes.
Es ging gegen die Herzschwäche.
Da ist die Liste.
Insgesamt 20 Tabletten am Tag.
Das ist eine Art Insulin.
Ich habe es über Insulin.
Ich habe es in der Nacht.
Ich habe es langzeitig.
Wie ist Ihre Blutzuckerwerte?
Das ist ein Problem bei mir.
Ich habe es regelmäßig zu kontrollieren.
Ich habe meine Hausarzt kontrolliert.
Er schimpft mit mir.
Ich habe meine Diät-Achte.
Zuletzt war es langzeitig zu gewährt.
Ich habe etwas zu gewertet.
Das war bei zehn.
Ich habe es zwischen sieben und acht.
Sie meinen, dass es möglich ist.
Das ist zu heiß.
Ich habe eine Diabetes-Achte.
Wie war Ihre Dästerkontrolle beim Hausarzt?
Das war vor einem Monat.
Da war es bei zehn.
Es war etwas angestiegen.
Wie war Ihre Blutzuckerwerte?
Sie missten zu Hause?
Früher habe ich das öfters gemessen.
Aber jetzt nicht mehr so oft.
Ich halte mich nicht an einer Strenge Diät.
Ich trinke gerne ein Wein.
Ich trinke auch mal ein süßes Getränk.
Ein Eisdäst.
Im Sommer habe ich viele Obst-Sachen gegessen.
Trauben, Wanderinen, Orangen.
Ich weiß, dass es nicht richtig ist.
Sie achten nicht auf Diät-Gut.
Hat sich Ihre Diäwig-Innester-Salz beantragt?
Es ist immer ein Auf und Ab.
Aber es hält sich bei dem 110 kg Stabine.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Sehr gut.
Haben Sie Schlachtprobleme?
Nein.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen?
Stuhlgang nicht.
Aber Wasserlassen muss ich auch.
Ich habe nicht Probleme beim Wasserlassen.
Ich muss auch nachts öfters auf die Toilette.
Aber Sie haben keine Schmerzen?
Nein, Schmerzen habe ich nicht mehr.
Schlafen Sie gut?
Ja, ich kann nicht mehr klagen.
Haben Sie
eine Augenarzt?
Ja, ich war letztes Jahr beim Arzt.
Mein Hausarzt schickt mich immer dahin.
Er sagt auch, die Augen sind ein bisschen schlecht
wegen dem Diabetes und dem hohen Blutdruck.
Ich gehe auch alle
ein paar Jahre zum Neurologen.
Das schickt mich meinen Hausarzt auch immer.
Ich habe mich auch immer in der Diäwig-Innester-Salz
geschaffen.
Okay.
Waren Sie für diese Beschwerden schon einmal beim Hausarzt?
Nein, ich bin jetzt zu Ihnen gekommen.
Das war jetzt, das war kurz vor mir aufgetreten.
Okay, das war gut.
Sie haben auch vor der Operation gesagt,
Sie sind post-traumlich.
Ich habe mich auch in der Diäwig-Innester-Salz
kontrolliert.
Ich glaube, ich habe auch die Impfungen.
Ich glaube, das ist genug.
Als Kind hatte ich eine Operation.
Ich glaube, die Blindarm ist raus.
Meine Mandeln sind operiert worden.
Ich habe mich auch in der Diäwig-Innester-Salz
kontrolliert.
Ich habe eine Operation, die die Blindarm-Innester-Salz
operiert worden.
Was habe ich noch als Kind raus?
Ich habe einen Leistenbruch als junger Mann gehabt.
Ich glaube, das war es.
Okay.
Waren Sie in der Diäwig-Innester-Salz im Ausland?
Nein.
Seit wann und wie viel ragen Sie?
Seit wann?
Seit ich 25 bin, glaube ich.
Ungefähr eine halbe Schachtel am Tag.
Haben Sie schon einmal versucht,
mit dem Rachen aufzuhören?
Nein, ich habe schon oft versucht.
Aber bin immer wieder rückwändig geworden.
Dann habe ich es aufgegeben.
Das ist sehr wichtig für Ihre Gesundheit.
Besonders mit dieser...
Sie haben recht.
Wenn Sie Hilfe brauchen,
wir sind immer da.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja.
Wie viel trinken Sie?
Gelegentlich nicht so viel.
Was meinen Sie,
wie gelegentlich einmal Woche oder Woche?
Also ich dann mal so...
ein bis zwei Flaschen Bier am Tag trinke ich schon.
Das ist also nicht so viel.
Und abends trinke ich gerne mal ein Wein zum Essen.
Ich glaube, das ist nicht gelegentlich.
Nein, Sie auch.
Das ist nicht viel.
Für jemand aus der Pfalz
ist das nicht viel.
Wir vertragen einiges.
Ich kenne da einige Freunde, die trinken schon viel mehr.
Das ist eigentlich ganz wenig, denke ich.
Okay.
Die folgende Frage ist eine Routinefrage.
Haben Sie oder hatten Sie Kontakt mit Drogen?
Nein.
Okay, das ist schon gut.
Herr Heckmann, jetzt möchte ich über Ihre Familien
ein paar Fragen stellen.
Leben Ihre Eltern noch?
Nein, meine Eltern sind leider schon verstorben.
Ja, es ist leider schon.
Woran sind Sie gestorben?
Hatten Sie eine Dorfdekrankheit?
Nein, leider.
Sie waren auf Urlaub.
Dann hatten Sie einen schweren Verkehrsunfall.
Und sind beide leider verstorben.
Ich kann das vorstellen.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Nein.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Wie ist Ihr Familienzustand?
Ich bin verheiratet.
Sie leben mit Ihrer Frau zusammen.
Was machen Sie beruflich?
Ich bin Sachbearbeiter.
Ich arbeite bei der Stadt.
Und mache dann Büroarbeit.
Haben Sie Stress bei der Arbeit?
Nein.
Als Beamter hat man eine
Verhandlung nicht.
Herr Heckmann, haben Sie alle
wie unter Unverträglichkeit?
Ja.
Was war das noch mal?
Ich muss Sie kurz überlegen.
Das kommt auch immer öfter vor.
Ich muss lange überlegen.
Ich vergesse auch sehr schnell.
Was haben Sie noch mal gefragt?
Haben Sie Allergien oder Unverträglichkeit?
Ja, ich habe eine Penicillinallergie.
Wie äußert sich diese Allergie?
Da kriege ich einen starken Ausschlag.
Das war ganz schlimm.
Haben Sie oft diese Gedächtnis?
Ja, das ist jetzt in letzter Zeit.
Ich merke selber, dass ich auch
lange überlegen muss.
Ich mache Sachen nicht sofort.
Ich habe mich nicht eingefallen.
Haben Sie Konzentration?
Ja, das hat auch nachgelassen.
Die Konzentration ist auch nicht mehr so,
wie es mal war.
Die Zeit ist fertig.
Ich habe noch eine Frage.
Ich habe keine weitere Frage.
Möchten Sie etwas hinstellen?
Ich hoffe, dass Sie mir helfen können.
Ich möchte Ihnen helfen.
Zuerst muss ich die Körper und die Untersuchung
und werde ich Blut abnehmen.
Ich werde die Untersuchungen führen.
Danach können wir die Anfängerung
auf die Hand nehmen.
Dann können wir die Sprache auf die Hand
beenden.
Ich kann die Untersuchungen klar sagen.
Okay, wunderbar.
Haben Kollegen oder Kollegen noch andere Fragen?
Darf ich fragen?
Gibt es etwas, das Ihre Beschwerde
im Datum erschreckt hat?
Nein, wenn ich jetzt im Schulbind
länger laufen möchte,
dann merke ich, dass der Schul drückt.
Was haben Sie für die Untersuchung
durchführen lassen?
Das war vor drei Monaten.
Darüber haben Sie informiert?
Ja, ich habe vorhin gesagt,
der Zuckerwert war bei den Zehnen.
Noch andere auffällige Untersuchungen?
Ja, das Kolesterol ist aber meistens etwas hoch.
Da beschwert sich mein Hausarzt immer.
Nierenwerte sind wohl auch etwas schlechter geworden.
Die Harnsäure ist glaube ich ein bisschen hoch.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Haben Sie Taubgefühl in Linken?
Ein Was, bitte?
Ich habe ein Taubheitsgefühl.
Ja, ich spüre, wenn man meinen Hausarzt
immer Untersuchungen macht
und immer eine Pinsel und eine Nadel.
Ich spüre da am Fuß nichts.
Das stimmt.
Es geht manchmal so weit,
dass ich in der gesamten Unterenwarte nichts spüre.
Oder man kribbeln.
Eine Kollegin hat geschrieben,
eine richtige Frage, weil sie haben gesagt,
eine Offenerwunde haben.
Haben Sie Fiber?
Ist der Haut feucht oder trocken?
An der Stelle, wo dieses Loch ist,
ist es nicht furchtig.
Ich muss dann immer so ein Flasch drüber kleben,
aber das wird immer nass.
Haben Sie in der letzten Zeit eine Kursen
neurologische Auswähle bemerkt?
Was sind neurologische Auswähle?
Was meine ich damit?
Was meine ich mit der Veränderung?
Eine Kurse-Visusverlust?
Was meine ich mit der Visusverlust?
Entschuldigung, ich verstehe das nicht.
Ich habe gesagt, Sprachstörung nicht.
Aber manche Wörter fallen mir schwer ein.
Ich kann mich schlecht konzentrieren.
Was haben Sie noch gefragt?
Mit einer Kurse seitdem ich in der letzten Zeit
wieder besser geworden habe?
Sie sind immer schlechter.
Diese Konzentration lässt nach.
Aber Sie haben Freude mit Visus?
Ja, haben Sie Probleme beim Sehen?
Meine Haus in meiner Augen sagt,
dass die Augen gefielden sind.
Das ist eine gute Frage.
Was haben Sie mit der Visusverlust?
Ich habe gesagt, dass die Augengefäße schlechter geworden sind.
Ich habe eine Brille für Sie.
Noch geht es eigentlich.
Aber ich merke, wenn ich abends Auto fahre,
dass die Lichter von den Autos
mich sehr blenden.
Ich kann abends sehr schlecht Auto fahren.
Das stimmt.
Ich denke, alle Fragen sind gestellt.
Können wir als Erster anfangen?
Vielleicht noch ein paar Worte zu der Untersuchung.
Der Blutdruck ist 170 zu 80.
Der Puls ist bei 60.
Der linke Fuß ist etwas kälter
als der rechte Fuß.
Man spürt, dass die Schmerzen
nicht mehr auf den Blutdruck sind.
Man kann sich nicht mehr auf den Blutdruck
auf den rechten Fuß.
Man spürt keinen Puls am Fuß rücken.
Der Haut ist etwas blass.
Die neurologischen Symptome sind,
dass er keine Impulse
oder Gefühle bis zum mittleren Waden hat.
Der Partier hat gesagt,
beim Laufen kein Problem.
Wir haben nicht mehr die Schmerzen.
Wir haben keine Schmerzen.
Wir haben auch Schwierigkeiten.
Ich sage, beim Laufen kein Problem.
Wir müssen ausführlich fragen,
wie viele Meter haben wir gelaufen.
Nach 100 Metern muss ich oft stehen bleiben.
Auf der Pulse machen.
Lediger, der Stabilität ist.
Wir haben ein Polidrauma.
sagen wir ein internistisches Polytrauma.
Polytrauma.
Internistisches Polytrauma.
Bitte schön, August.
Hallo, guten Abend.
Ah, liebe Kollegen, guten Abend, guten Abend.
Sie haben immer so interessante Patientinnen, erzählen Sie mal.
Was haben Sie mit der Doktor?
Es geht um Herr Manuel Fickmann.
Er ist 54 Jahre alt, 1,70 m groß und 110 kg schwer.
Oh, ja, ja, ja.
Er stärkte sich bei uns wegen Zeit,
um ein bis zwei Jahre progradierende Parästhesie im Linken-Bahn.
Parästhesie, ne?
Parästhesie und Taupais-Gebü.
Ja, Parästhesie.
Imse mal, dann schauen wir, ob es eine Parästhesie ist
oder ob es eine Polyneuropathie ist
oder ob das etwas anderes ist.
Aber sie hat ja auch die Hülstörungen.
Ja, ja, Missempfiehung.
Ja, Grippen und Taupais-Gebü in Linken-Bahn
und in der 5., 5.
Nein, nicht so.
Der Patient habe auch Schmerzen,
manchmal in diesem Bereich, besonders beim Laufen.
Er hatte keine Umfalt oder Verletzung gehabt.
Er hatte keine Trauma.
Er hat eine Ulkos-Ulseration im Kleinen-Zee bemerkt.
Wo am Kleinen-Zee?
Im Linken-Zee.
Wo am Zee, genau?
Ist es der ganze Zee?
Oder ist es der Fuhl?
Oder ist es im Äußeren, den seitlichen Bereich?
Ja, das müssen Sie schon genau beschreiben vor Doktor.
Wie groß ist die offene Stelle?
Ja, ich habe das nicht gefragt,
weil der Körper die Unterhörungen mehr.
Ein Ulkus, wie nennt sich dieser Ulkus?
Ulkus, nicht Ulkus Kurus, aber das ist...
Ja, recht Ulkus Kurus.
Ulkus Kurus.
Das ist ein grösser, lateralen Grundgelenk
der kleinen Zee des Linken-Fuses.
Wie groß ist dieser Ulkus?
Erbsen groß, ein Euro groß.
Wie tief ist dieser Wunde?
Ich weiß, hat der Patient nicht gefragt,
aber Sie haben es gesehen.
Das ist ein kleiner Ulkus von ca. 5 mm Durchmesser.
Und die Wunde ist tief.
Es geht bis auf den Knochen runter.
Sie sehen das Gelenk.
Jetzt müssen Sie die Wunde ein bisschen beschreiben.
Ist die Wunde vereitert?
Ist die Blutend?
Ist die entzündet?
Der Patient habe gesagt, dass er nass im Socken bemerkt.
Das heißt, es einträgt.
Eine feuchte, nässe Wunde.
Jetzt ist die Frage, war Eiter dabei?
War das Eiträg?
Nein, ein Eiter war dabei.
Keiner.
Die Frage nach Schwellenbund und Rötung, Überwärmung
oder belästigem Haut, wurde zu einer Neu.
Was haben Sie gesehen?
Sie haben den Fuß untersucht.
Ich habe vorhin gesagt, der Fuß ist kalt.
Der Fuß ist kalt.
Und keine perfekte Tasse.
Der Patient hat einen Ulkus Kuris.
Am linken kleinen C.
Die Wunde geht tief bis auf den Knochen.
Es ist nicht vereitert, sondern eine nässe Wunde.
Was hat der Patient noch?
Der Patient hat Polierie und Nüctare.
Polierie oder Polaxie?
Polierie und Nüctare.
Was hat der Patient für Erkrankungen erzählt?
Er hat Arterialepipartoni mit 40 Jahren.
Und Diabetes meldet über 20 Jahre.
Wie wird der Diabetes behandelt?
Mit Langzeitinsulin.
3-mal.
Langzeitinsulin? Nein.
Es ist ein insulin behandelter Diabetes.
Er hat einen Langzeiturin, das nimmt er abends.
Er nimmt ein normales Insulin.
Er hat eine Prostatahepiparpolasie.
Er hat eine Prostatatapurasie.
Er hat keine Ruheschmerzen in der Ruh.
Er hat weniger als 100 Meter.
Er hat eine Prostatatapurasie.
Er hat eine Stanz.
Er hat eine Herzinkrankung.
Er hat eine Herzinfarkt.
Er hat eine Diskusprolapse.
Er hat sein Brust, wie wir sie gebrochen sind, vor fünf Jahren.
Er hat eine Prostatapurasie.
Er hat eine Antwort.
Er hat eine Besung.
Er hat eine Krebs.
Er hat eine Rächte.
Er hat eine Penicillin-Alargie bei ihm bekannt.
Er hat eine Diagnose.
Wie lange sind Sie schon Ärztin?
2013 habe ich mein Studium abgeschlossen.
Ich habe in einem Jahr überdrückt Medizin gearbeitet.
Sie sind Ärztin mit der Tauchmedizin.
Ich habe viele Diabetes und Urkustrylis.
Es ist sehr kompliziert.
Diabetes ist kompliziert.
Die Folgeschäden von Diabetes mit Gefäßdurchblutungsstörungen,
Neurologischen Problemen, Hautproblemen, Ulzerar.
Sie nehmen ihre Medikamente.
Er hat eine beginnende vasculare Demenz.
Er hat eine Mikroangipathie im Hirn.
Im internistischen Sprachgebrauch sagen wir zu solchen Patienten
ein internistisches Polytrauma.
Das ist ein schwerer kranker Mensch mit 54 Jahren.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Wie soll man diese Patienten fragen?
Sie haben gemerkt, dass der Patient nicht viel versteht.
Er hat Gefühlsstörungen, Armeisen, Misempfindungen.
Ich habe eine andere Frage.
Ich habe eine Frage.